what kind of an impact has Dominic
raab's alleged bullying had on civil
servants in his Department well I think
it's important that we don't go into
details of the allegations they are
being investigated and confident
confidentiality is critical I'm asking
you about the impact
um I I've spoken to people who are civil
servants uh working and have worked for
Dominic Raab who have suffered Mental
Health crisis have
lost their careers essentially because
they've had to to move and and change
jobs billing has an enormous impact on
individuals it's about an abuse of power
and the in many cases there's no greater
power Dynamic than someone who is a
government minister or a deputy prime
minister and the civil servant and where
that gets abused it can have significant
consequences for individuals how many
people are we talking about uh I don't
know exactly there are eight complaints
of which we understand I think a couple
of dozen civil servants are involved in
it it covers three different government
departments it covers a period of about
four years and in any other employment
context if that was you me or anyone
else in the workplace up and down the
country the employer would consider
suspending someone because with
allegations so significant you have to
have regard for your current employees
and whether essentially you're putting
them In Harm's Way if potentially
someone who is a could be a prolific
bully is still allowed to be in the
workplace and that's what the Prime
Minister should address and address
there's lots to talk about there let me
unpack it if I may so you say at least
eight allegations covering a couple of
dollars and civil servants
um what has been the outcome for some of
those civil servants you say they've
lost their careers yeah if if you're in
a workplace where you're being bullied
where you're The Daily Grind of coming
to work destroys your mental health then
that is an impact on your career about
you know these jobs working with
ministers in many ways are the Pinnacle
of a civil servants clearance at the top
of the Civil Service then in some of the
most important jobs and civil service
and to leave that as part of your career
or be forced out because you can't cope
with it it's hugely damaging to your
career and and your life well let me put
this to you Jacob risma was where you
are a couple of days ago and this is
what he had to say
is it reasonable to demand from senior
and well-paid professionals a level of
good service and then you have to judge
whether that line has been overstepped
but I do worry that we are getting a bit
snow flaky about this
bit snow flaking I was astonished by
those comments Jacob Lee smog was leader
of the House of Commons I know that he
met with people who were the victims of
bullying in the Commons he's had
firsthand what it's like to be on the
wrong end of bullying in to talk about
snowflakeery in those terms is just
astonishing from someone in his position
this this sort of behavior destroys
lives I mean it's not just about careers
people's lives and their mental health
are at risk when they are subject to
systematic bullying and to belittle it
in that way is absolutely outrageous
from a former leader of the house and
cabinet Ministry well let me put this to
you from the education secretary Julian
Keegan
I think actually it was Dom himself who
instigated this investigation
um so that's ongoing I sit around the
cabinet table and you know don't see
don't see that right I don't see any you
know I feel very comfortable with my
colleagues around the cabinet table
doesn't see any bullying billing is
about the abuse of power so the power
dynamic between the Secretary of State
for education and the Deputy Prime
Minister is very different from the
power dynamic between a minister and a
civil servant so Vanessa should know
that when they talk about they haven't
witnessed it they wouldn't witness it
because they are in a different position
from a civil servant or someone who can
be bullied by someone as powerful as a
deputy prime minister why should he be
suspended because you or I or anyone
else would be if we were in that
situation why should government
ministers be any different if any
employer faces significant allegations
against someone they have to look at
their current employees and if you're
faced with eight separate allegations
from three different parts of your
organization over a period of four years
involving dozens of people that suggests
there is a real issue there and a real
danger
um for the health and safety of com
staff until you can establish Gil or
instance you have to protect your
current Workforce well I spoke to number
10 about this this morning and they said
that there's a long-standing principle
that ministers should continue to carry
out their duties while an investigation
is ongoing the the prime minister is
also Minister for the Civil Service he
has an obligation to civil servants if
it concludes at the end of this
investigation that it's correct that
Dominic Rabb is a bully that all of
those allegations are correct what it
means is in the meantime he has been
allowed potentially to bully civil
servants and while sees that the
secretary of state that is the issue
that the Prime Minister needs to contend
with he wants this power he has decided
he will not allow an independent system
to deal with complaints and with that
power comes responsibility including
protecting current civil servants
friends of Dominic Robb who work within
government including two senior civil
servants saying that this is a clear
attempt by politically motivated
mandarins to get him that's
extraordinary and it couldn't be further
from the truth in actual fact I've
spoken to people who didn't raise
concerns at the time because they
understood the political impact of it
they were reticent about challenging
Behavior because they understood at that
point in time it would be seen as a
politically motivated attack civil
servants are politically impartial they
want to serve the government of the day
and do the best job but they have to be
protected and work in an environment
where they are not bullied for doing
that and to suggest that they're
actually got some political motivation
and we've really seen two dozen civil
servants in three different government
departments over a period of four years
I've got together with some massive
conspiracy that just doesn't uh it's so
incredible why have they waited years to
come forward because it's really
difficult to raise complaints again I've
spoken to some of the people involved in
this and they said they'll look at what
happened with pretty Patel the Prime
Minister was forced into an
investigation he sat on that report for
six months and when he was forced to
actually conclude on it he ignored the
recommendations that she had bullied
civil servants and breached the
ministerial code so they got a clear
message the only way you can complain
about a minister is to go through the
Prime Minister and that prime minister
was not interested in allegations
against his political allies what do you
think he knew when do you think this
prime minister knew about allegations
against his well the reports are that he
was briefed and if you look look at what
he says he's he's telling us what he
doesn't know he hasn't telling us what
he does no I think the Prime Minister
needs to come clean it would be normal
practice that when a prime minister is
appointing cabinet ministers he would be
told of any concerns whether that was a
formal complaint or not he may well have
been aware that there were concerns
about Dominic's rugby May well that's
you don't think well we don't know
because he won't answer the question he
repoint blankly refuses to say whether
he was told of an informal complaints
about Dominic Rabb and if he was what
did he do with that did he say that
wasn't important if those concerns were
raised about his behavior that really
didn't matter what was more important
was given a job to a political Ally we
need to know and the reason why benitino
is because the Prime Minister has to
decide on this investigation the Casey
involved doesn't decide on it he only
establishes a fact so the prime minister
is the one who at the end we've just had
this from the PM's press secretary so
let me put this to you and see what you
say in the result the prayer was not
aware of any formal complaints at the
time of appointing Dominic robs yes
that's what he keeps saying he keeps
relying that no because there were no
formal complaints because the only way
you can make a formal complaint is for
the prime minister of the day to agree
that there would be an investigation
he's not being asked where there were
formal complaints he's asked about
whether he was aware of any informal
concerns about Dominic Rabb and once
again he is refusing to answer that
point let me ask you one final question
if I may um we had labor on the program
yesterday they said that he needs to be
suspended as a matter of urgency because
there are concerns about uh not all not
only the welfare but also the safety of
those people in his department is that
going too far it's not going too far
that's what would happen to anyone else
in this country why should government
ministers be exempt from what would be
the rules that apply to everyone else
faced with significant allegations of
bullying it would be normal practice to
suspend someone until such times have
you been able to establish the the
whether they are valid or not that's
what should happen in this case